we think 14-year old joke you'll see wha  is an artist you should know like a lot  more music coming out with her trademark  hair bows JoJo's anti-bullying anthem  boomerang has racked up more than 300  million views on YouTube 100 I was like  like why is it doing so then people love  it because of the message now she's been  named Nick Cannon sidekick on the  Nickelodeon series lip sync battle  shorties Jojo has a new book a doll and  she's getting her own Nickelodeon  special my world so basically it's all  leading up to my sub performing studies  at at Mall of America so it's like the  rehearsals pray that the preparation  turn out and she's stuck forshoyp on I  want to be like Britney Spears I want to  do the whole music thing I don't want to  do the whole Vegas thing that is my goal  in life  [Music]